hello and welcome back to our show now
Westminster is back this week so we
wanted to bring you one of the biggest
voices in British politics Labor's
Deputy leader Angela Rayner
she's a politician with working class
roots from the left of the party who was
promoted to the front bench in her first
few months as an MP but her rise wasn't
without controversy especially as the
party shifted back to the center ground
under circus starmer but she's never
stopped speaking her mind
people have underestimated me all my
life if I'm honest you know and I
remember the stigma that I faced when I
was a young mum at 16 and it still Burns
now later the opposition Angela Rainer
who had Revel in the opportunity for the
people of this country to have more than
just by-elections to see what they think
of this Government College general
election and see where the people are
prime minister how's it going are you
okay it's great to be here with the the
right honorable Lady of the Shadows
happy to stay for the future of work we
know the future of the job that she has
in mind it might be a bacon super Prime
assistant so maybe I should have
aspirations the reason our results are
about what the government did especially
on the school meals was because I was a
child that was hungry and the Prime
Minister describes my constituents as
letterboxers and then my constituents to
suffer their racism on our streets
that's why I get passionate if the Prime
Minister wants to remove himself from
those comments I'm quite happy to
apologize for calling him scum with a
party that's going to win with a party
of government let's rise to the moment
with our labor government in power once
again
now the labor leadership wants an
election but can they really win latest
Poland suggests they can months of Chaos
in the conservative party have gifted
labor a golden opportunity with 46
percent of Voters Now set to back them
Angela Rayner then looks on course to
becoming the next Deputy Prime Minister
the tasks now don't slip up and convince
voters you have the credentials to
govern
the public will though need to hear
solutions to ongoing strikes the growing
pressure on the NHS and a cost of living
crisis squeeze in us all so what does
labor have to offer the country
foreign
ER thanks for coming on the show today
and I want to talk a lot about Angie
Rayner the woman who you are in your
political views but before I get on to
that I want to talk to you about the
story dominating politics about it is of
course the NHS now Kia satama has said
that the NHS is not on its knees it's on
its face so for voters watching this
interview can you tell us whether if
they do vote labor in 2024 they can be
confident that the NHS will get more
money under a labor government well
we're very clear it's not just about
what money is invested in the NHS it's
also about where that money is going to
social care has been absolutely
decimated since 2010 I was a home care
worker worked in Social care I built
social care and many of the colleagues
who were trained up under the last Labor
government to deliver care in the
community we then made redundant under
the cuts that were given to local
government so we've got a real crisis
now not just affecting our NHS but
because we're not able to give Primary
Care in the community and our focus is
not only around bringing waiting lists
down like the last Labor government did
but about investing in Social care and
caring the community so that people get
the care when they need it you know
Boris Johnson did try and put more money
into social care he announced a tax
raising plan it was going to put 12
billion pounds in tax Rises to put into
social care now the conservatives have
since reversed that policy but in
principle did you agree with that idea
that you have to raise taxes in order to
better fund the Health Service and
social care now I think at the moment
because we're spending so much money on
people being in hospital beds when it's
not required people not getting the
early intervention in social care that
they need we're spending huge amounts of
money on giving people care at the wrong
time in the wrong place I have actually
been inspired by the work we did in
local government back when I was a home
carer that meant more people were
delivering the service in their own
homes when they needed it and preventing
them going into chronic care and into
hospitals you will save huge amounts of
money that could be redirected social
Community Care so whilst at the
beginning you may have to bring in
reforms and it may take a bit of time to
move that money away from other services
to put into preventative care I actually
think the key to this is not just about
just throwing money out I mean it's
about the reforms
the care when they need it the most but
given the situation in the NHS and a lot
of people watching this will think the
notion of Labor a head of election
committing to put more money into the
NHS more than the Tories would do it's
not a particularly controversial
expectation for voters to have but you
don't really don't want to commit to
that it's not the Cure this is what I'm
trying to get over to people it's not
just about throwing money into the NHS
the NHS needs support or it needs staff
proper staff rather than agency workers
and the vacants we have because people
are
we've got waiting list where people are
getting more and more unwell so people
are needing more help so it's costing
the NHS and it's costing taxpayers more
so Angie you're you as the deputy leader
at the moment not committing uh to
putting any more money into the NHS
you're going to stick with the
conservative spending plan I know you've
got the notebook for example we've said
the non-dom states
that you use to fund training of nurses
and doctors but beyond that what you're
saying at the moment is no avert
commitment from labor for more spending
it's about intending in the right place
you will save money
clarification that you are online as on
the left of the party you're aligned
with Starman where's streets and about
no confidence yeah I'm confident we can
help the NHS we'll spend more on
Recruitment and also we will give people
the right care when they need them I
don't want to get too bogged down in
this so let's move on to something else
which is private healthcare now the
prime minister's got stick for not
answering the question about whether he
was registered with a private GP whether
he still is he won't say he says It's A
Private Matter do you agree with that or
do you think he should tell the public
no I think it you know it's completely
choice if he does have private
healthcare but he should tell the public
about that I think it is important
um you know I don't have private Health
Care never have have you ever used
Private health care well I'm on the
record saying that I had um a a
procedure done on me when I was younger
that I paid for myself and not one-off
procedure so that would be considered
that I use that service but certainly
not for my day-to-day stuff and in fact
my son was born at 23 weeks gestation
and you know if it wasn't for the NHS
quite frankly my son would be here today
so I value the NHS there's no way I
could have been able to help my son
survive and get through that period
without the NHS there's no way I could
have afforded would you ever use Private
health I mean I know you're talking
about a kind of Cosmetics but would you
ever use
Private health if you couldn't get an
appointment or just on principle you
wouldn't feel comfortable doing it I
think we should be supporting our NHS
because it's so important that people
need to be able to get the care for the
issues that these are chronic issues
we've got to fix the NHS and it's so
important and I'm sorry but we should
not looked out a touch when he talked
about the it not being an NHS crisis at
the moment I've seen many consultants
doctors and nurses who are literally
saying I've never seen it so bad in the
NHS at the moment and people are
genuinely frightened that I'm frightened
that if you try and contact the NHS when
you need it they're not going to be able
to get to you because we've had alerts
about ambulances don't ring for an
ambulance you won't be able to get one
at the moment labor is using private
provision for the NHS
that's quite a big change from stormers
original position in 2020 when he's
elected to be leader to end Outsourcing
in the NHS
do you think it should be Labor's
aspiration to end that use of Private
health care as soon as Compass capacity
can be found in the nhsi that's sticking
plaster to fix a particular problem post
pandemic and that it should end as soon
as possible what's your position our
position is very clear on it that we
would use the capacity in the private
sector to bring down those waiting lists
in the long term we've also got the
commitment to invest more in the NHS by
creating more vacant you know
recruitment for doctors for nurses for
health care assistance for midwives so
that we can increase the capacity within
the NHS so we want to end Outsourcing
you've always been if you like a
standard Bearer I would say of the left
of the party I know that you're elected
in your own right and you have your own
political identity but for Lots on the
left you're you're there woman in Shadow
cabinet you served in Corbin Shadow
cabinet Shadow education secretary does
it trouble you sometimes that kills
storm has abandoned so many of his plan
edges the ones that design that were
designed to show the left he could be
trusted that he abandoned so many of
those pledges that he made in 2020 to be
elected
it's awkward isn't it what I would say
and the overriding principle is about
delivery and Delivery for the public you
know the last Labor government and this
I spoke about when I was in corbyn's
shuttle cabinet the last Labor
government delivered so much for
working-class people like me from the
council Estates that I grew up on from
the shore Start center from the free
adult education from the support that I
was given you know with Income Support
getting back into work the tax credit
system that the last Labor government
brought in all of those things delivered
enabled me to get on in life and to be
sat in front of you here today so it's
about delivery we're not about pragma
we're not we're not about ideological
we're driven about how can we deliver
pragmatically based in what we're going
to be you know if then we win the next
election what we're going to inherit
from the government which is a very bad
economic situation you know productivity
is low in the UK we've got a plan on how
we deliver to improve our public
services and deliver productivity and
fix the economy and that's the
overriding pitch for us it's not an
ideologically driven so it's about
delivering to people so it's sort of
sacrifice principles for power or don't
let principles block the risk let
principles block the investment and the
support and the delivery for the British
public you know principles are important
I I've got those principles and I
actually think those principles will
deliver but it's also important that
people can see that you've got a radical
plan but a realistic and responsible
plan it's the three hours for me radical
realistic and responsible so in a way
Angie have you been on your own journey
in the sense that you've been in the
shadow Covenant you've been out of power
you've been working really hard but you
can't actually affect change
for seven years since I became a labor
MP I've watched us lose votes time and
time again I developed a National
Education Service I've developed the
national procurement plan and ethics and
integrity commission the future of work
the program that we've got none of that
will ever happen unless we convince the
British public that we are responsible
about getting into government and we can
deliver on those on that program and
that's what we're focused on it's not
about getting rid of my principles I
believe in my principles and I continue
to but you know when I was a free School
meals kid principles would not fed me it
was the free School meals program that
the labor government brought in when I
was a mum at 16 it was a sure start
Webster Stratton program that labor
brought in that was able to help me to
become a good movement to look after my
son
what's your message to the left of the
party when they look at Starman and says
I'm not getting the spending check but
out there won't be any more money for
the NHS we have to stick within
conservative party spending guidelines
and the left of the party go hang on a
minute this isn't what I signed up for
this isn't what I believe this isn't
what I want what's your message to the
left of the party what hang in there we
can be more radical in government
I would argue that care isn't the same
we have to stick to conservative
spending plans kids very clear that
actually conservatives have been
disastrous for this country productivity
is low they crashed the economy our
Public Services have been you know
downtrodden and are in a critical State
because of the lack of investment from
from the government he's talked about
actually we do need radical program
Great British energy is a radical
program our Green New Deal are looking
at how we can do new deal for work and
people's about raising standards and
about doing things in the long term to
put the country on a better so I know
it's a bit hard but in 1997 Tony Blair
and golden brown promised to stick to
story spending plans for two years so
you wouldn't accept that that's not
where you're at the moment notorious
have completely crashed the economy
inflation's at its highest level tax is
at its highest level we don't want to do
what the conservatives have done for the
last 13 years because they've run down
Public Services
it's about trust isn't it and and the
reason I want to raise up with you
Andrew is because and I'll move on after
this but just finally on the starmer
issue he did make big purchase in
writing rather than like a Manifesto
internally for labor members in which he
said and I'll quote it public services
and energy and water he wanted in public
hands he now seems to abandon all of
that agenda but rail so how can people
trust him because he says one thing to
get elected and then he does something I
don't think he has abandoned them what
he's talked about is realistically what
are our priorities in a labor government
and how do we deliver better for that
public right I get that some people are
trying to say if you say this at this
particular time then you've got to stick
to that forever but actually what Kier
said is Great British energy which will
be you know
um a corner of what we do in government
he's talked about investing in public
services he's talked about improving
workers right it's for the New Deal for
working people so actually the theme of
what we're trying to do is to say
actually yes this this is a government
that will reform Britain to get
productivity moving again and to
increase the you know support to our
public sector and improve it one thing
starmer did tell the guardian he doesn't
want a wealth tax which is you pay one
percent tax on days on above 10 million
quid you'll know that all with assets
above or wealth above 10 million pounds
but he did say dividends on rental
incomes are the sort of things he
considered is it time for landlords to
pop to pay more well I think at the
moment people have seen their rents
going up and actually at the same time
as people have had you know their their
tax burden go up the same time landlords
are not paying extra on their properties
when they've got a huge amount of a
property portfolio so of course that's
something that we should look at because
again like I say the principal is around
fairness one case commented his speech
last week and the main thing about the
radical Vision was about Devolution and
pushing power back into communities but
it wasn't about tax and spending and it
struck me it reminded me of the Roy
Jenkins description of Tony Blair in 97
that he was man you'll know it carrying
a Priceless mingvars across a highly
polished floor I.E didn't want to slip
up he didn't want to do anything that
spooked voters he just wanted to make
sure that they won that election even
though it was Miles Ahead in the polls
is that kind of where kirstan was at now
and where you're at now as well but
where were at is I mean in 2019 we got
one of our worst defeats in history you
know to come to where we are today to
get the voters to even give us the
opportunity to speak to them
um is quite an achievement and we
understand that and we understand the
volatility in that as well and the
preciousness in the way that the public
still need to see more from labor in
order for we don't take the polling for
granted for example we know there's a
long way for us to go so we're doing
that but we also know if you looked at
the last 12 months who'd have thought
the Tories would have crashed the
economy and Liz trust would have within
40 days I mean you did what she did so
who knows where we're going to be in 12
months the Johnson implosion followed by
the the trust economic difficulties it's
been great for you hasn't it
personally I'm spending more on my
mortgage and everything it's not been
that great I can tell you if you're
living in this country at the moment the
trust the truth regime was disastrous no
and that's absolutely and even actually
to be fair to vishi sunak even he
predicted that this would be but it's a
disaster he was in the cabinet allowed
that to happen people are having to
remortgage around a very different
environment and it's and it's put
pressure and it will also impact the
next Labor government because we won't
be able to do what we want to do because
absolutely good for you in that it's
it's prompted people to take another
look at Labor yeah well no because I
think I think part of the reason yeah I
mean the tourists have disastrously
failed and and I think that's part of
why the polling is where it is today but
actually here and my leadership I think
has shown that the labor party is
changing and I think that's what's
giving us an opportunity you can't just
rely on the conservatives doing a very
bad job when you arrived in Westminster
seven years ago and you know you left
school you had a baby when you were 16.
you you know you became a union rep and
you became very successful and then now
you're the deputy leader of the labor
party elected by members you know you
own that that's not patronage from Star
but that's your you earned that job
you have done incredibly well
you've probably defied expectations
about people around you perhaps when you
were younger about what your limitations
could or couldn't be right when you got
to Westminster did you just think
there's no one like me here no one gets
it no one has a back not backstory but
no one's from a background like I am and
these people just don't get it was it
lonely I didn't understand that it was
such a big Network here I never you know
I've been to London a couple of times as
a union rep to to our headquarters for
the union but before then I mean when I
was growing up my world was three
streets on the estate I grew up in I
didn't even go to Manchester I lived in
Stockport which is a town just in
outside of Manchester Manchester was a
huge thing never mind London never mind
you know politics and government but the
driving force that I've always had is
about trying to do the right thing my
nana taught me that she said always do
your best
always do your best and I've always
tried to do the right thing and when I
became pregnant at 16 I wanted to prove
that I could be a good Mom I wanted to
you know love my child and do the best I
can for him the fact that I wasn't able
to parent him well until I understood
that you know the needs of being a good
parent was was not my fault the fact
that I was struggling at the beginning
and had to have Income Support to help
me it wasn't necessarily my fault there
was factors in my life that made those
challenges more severe for me so now I
have an understanding that you know me
being in a unique privileged position of
being here is about delivery for the
people that like me needs that change
now and needs someone that understands
their challenges that they face nobody
likes living in poverty it's not fun
it's not fun living with a chronic
condition and not being able to get the
support you need so you can go out to
work it makes you feel like you're an
inadequate person because you can't
deliver government to me is about
delivering understanding that those
challenges that people face and then
delivering them the opportunities and
the hope that they can have a better
future that's what labor did for me
that's why I'm in the labor party now to
deliver that and if I could become
Deputy Prime Minister that will be my
focus is my driving force is to deliver
for people so that they can better their
lives and improve their circumstances
do you think that it does remain a
barrier like you might believe that you
can do it but in the in in a very
stratified
Society driven by class identification
if you like that even if you believe it
the public maybe don't is that a barrier
I mean class is still I think a really
big issue social and economic situations
of people where they start from we've
seen social Mobility you know decrease
over the last 13 years and we've seen
inequality grow in this country I think
there are big barriers and you can't get
away from them their reality I've seen
it every day the misogyny that I faced
and you know people who are watching
this will know that in their everyday
lives but I think that one of the
reasons that I still get up in the
morning I think no I'm not going to be
disgraced into saying you know I I feel
bad about my accent or I'm not not
worthy enough to be here is because I am
worthy enough to be here I have a
Manchester accent but it's because where
I grew up and if you go to my local user
they all sound like me because that's
how we sound where I'm from and I'm not
perfect I'm not I do make mistakes but
everybody does and I think the more
human eye can be and not try to be
something I'm not not try and Inspire to
be something I'm not and just try and
make the change because I care enough to
want to change things for people I think
it's the best way I can change it for
the next Generation famously you're
accused of crossing and uncrossing your
legs to distract Boris Johnson
which I know must have really upset you
you were then also you gave this very
interesting lengthy interview in the
financial times a really long piece
about your background and your political
beliefs and your your struggles and your
triumphs and the only part anyone
reported from that was your boob job is
that frustrating for you do you just
think come on like why it's sexist it is
a little bit but it's also about I'm an
open book you know I don't try and I say
care under shares and I overshare that's
the difference between me and Kim I will
over share and part of that is about I
am I am just a normal person like
everybody else you know but it is
frustrating when you see the misogyny
that I face you know that Onslaught
saying suggesting you know ludicrously
that I cross known across my legs it's
the last thing to think about quite
frankly when I'm doing pmqs I'm thinking
I need to do a good job here thinking
about what I'm going to ask and about
the issues of the day I'm not thinking
about is somebody looking at my legs
it's just ridiculous to think that but
women face that every single day so if I
go oh this is you know I've got to I've
got to take it on and what really gave
me Comfort actually about that is every
time they've I've been attacked for
things like that the public have really
pushed back and said actually no hang on
a minute this is not okay to attack
Angie on a policies attack Angie on on a
politics professionally but on her how
she appearance how she speaks you know
that's not acceptable and that's given
me a huge amount of painting in the
British public because they see through
that they don't want to see that side of
their politics they want to know you're
going to do a good job did you wish you
hadn't talked about that procedure now
are you just like no no because I just
think it's who I am you know this is
what people face every single day you
know I'd add my children and you know
I'd lost six stone in weight after I had
my children and there was nothing I
could do for it you know there was
nothing else I could do but that and it
was causing me emotional distress so I
chose out of my own money that I worked
hard for to pay to have that procedure
done I think that's quite a challenge
that most women face they they can make
that decision if you want to wear makeup
that's your decision what you want to
wear is your decision it shouldn't
detract from you as a professional or
you as a human being I think that's
quite the most normal thing that you can
do and I'm not going to pretend that
having those
um challenges in life and making choices
like that are not something that that I
make as an individual myself also makes
you more human I am human I have the
challenges Every Other Woman faces I
worry I'm not doing enough for my
children when I'm at work I worry I'm
not doing enough for work when I'm at
home you know we all have these
challenges about and I worry about those
things and I think the more you can be
honest and open about how you are as an
individual I think I'm not expecting
everyone to be the same as me but just
to say I'm just normal I just have the
same challenges everybody else faces
we've been doing this in Westminster
accounts just quickly as being an MP a
full-time job do you think do you think
people shouldn't have second jobs I do
think it's a full-time job and we set up
the we've said that in government we set
up an Ethics commission and therefore
they would then look at what we consider
to be obviously if you're an emergency
doctor and being able to practice to
keep your you know your doctorate is
important but actually the ethics
commission would look at that but I
don't think that second jobs is what MP
should be about it should we should be
focused on I mean I don't get time in
the day to do la my day no I I look
I did have a quick look at your run as
though 1400 quid yeah right so you're
not you're not you get lots of donations
for your office but in terms of running
I mean the amount of money that I'd
received previously was to do with the
deputy leadership campaign because in
order to run for Deputy leader I had to
have a team that and we were able to go
up and down the country that's not
funded by the taxpayer it's not funded
by the labor but that's also a bit of a
barrier so it is a barrier it's a huge
barrier but the reason why those monies
and they're openly declared were because
otherwise if I'd hadn't had donations I
wouldn't have been able to run to be
Deputy lead with a labor party look I'm
not gonna I don't but someone like David
Lammy though he's made a lot of money
yes from radio shows but also from
speeches like of JP Morgan and Facebook
and Google do you think MP should do
that no I'm not talking about David per
se but is that something you think MPS
maybe shouldn't do if it enables I think
it's a bit of a gray area because if it
enables you to get out to the public and
enables you to raise your voice in there
being as a substantial person then I
think that's quite important part of
what you do as an MP anyway and it's not
just about how much you earn from it
it's actually about how does that
contribute to your job as an MP and to
public Life as a politician and you know
making huge amounts of money
um off you know things that don't
actually represent your constituents I
think is a different matter but I don't
think it's for me to decide that this is
why we'd set up a independent ethics
commission that looks at these things
and I I'm just going to ask you one more
thing because I'm totally pushing my
luck but strikes your work you you
obviously in the cabinet office when you
become if you become I should say if you
become a deputy uh prime minister do you
still want to have the cabinet office
job are you do you want to just be so
you want you want to run the cabinet off
so yeah you're working all the
anti-strike the government working on
the anti-strike legislation what's your
message you were a union rep yourself
yeah what's your take on the stripes
situation government's own assessment
says it won't work look this legislation
they want to bring in actually it's
stoking up tensions and actually at the
moment I've known for years I mean even
when I went on industration we always
had derogations and exemptions I mean we
saw more ambulance stuff on in that day
than we saw on a picket line because
they were out obviously doing their job
it's ridiculous what the government are
doing they've stoked up the tensions
they're deliberately trying to make a
straw man over the strike actions no
General Secretary of a trade Union can
force their members out it's the last
thing that Trade union members want to
do go on Industrial action this
government has closed down talks thrown
spanners in the works at the last minute
and have deliberately tried to stoke up
the tensions and then say it's the union
Baron's fault the unions want to find a
negotiated settlement they did in Wales
and we would deliver that as a labor
government and we can see that the
challenges that working people face
today on the inflation on the cost of
living and because of this mismanagement
of the economy because of this
government and labor will change that so
we will make the economy grow we will
deliver for public services and we will
negotiate with the trade unions in a
constructive way okay well Andrew thank
you so much for giving me so much of
your time and we got through a lot of
ground there so we really appreciate it
thank you no problem thank you
a candid Angela Rayner there on a
crucial year ahead for the labor party
and its hopes of regaining power and if
you scan this QR code on screen now you
can watch all of our interviews online
and all of the previous episodes of the
show well that's all for this week's
show thank you to my guest Angela Rayner
and thank you for watching it's great to
be back
[Music]